what words do you have for Harry Don's
family today have a nice day
have you compounded their grief by
delaying Justice for three years and
sakulas had just been on a video link in
America watching a court in London
sentence her for the killing of 19 year
old Harry Dunn why didn't you go to
attend court in the UK as the U.S spy
got into the lift in Washington DC there
were no further answers you are not
getting in this elevator okay go ahead
there was little sign of the remorse
she'd expressed in court for the crash
that she caused three years ago outside
the American intelligence space at Raf
Croton in northamptonshire the U.S
government refused permission for
ansakulas to travel to the old bayley
for her sentencing like any other
defendant and the judge made it very
clear that she could see no justifiable
reason why sakulas wasn't here in person
facing British Justice
please stand up Mrs sekulas the
sentencing was on camera you are
disqualified from driving for 12 months
for the offense of causing the death of
Harry Dunn by your careless driving the
sentence is eight months imprisonment
suspended for 12 months
a statement was read out on behalf of
Mrs sakulas it said my tragic mistake
led to the loss of Harry and I live with
this regret every single day there is
not a day that goes by that Harry isn't
on my mind and I am deeply sorry for the
pain that I have caused as always I
remain willing to meet and apologize to
Harry's family directly if that would
support their healing
Harry's family have had three years
fighting for this moment after sakulas
was allowed to leave the UK claiming
diplomatic immunity
for me the next best thing was to kiss
that bruised lip a bit and just let him
know that I'll Fight For Justice you
know that's the promise that I made to
him was that I promised I would get him
Justice and
that's what's kept me going that's been
my driver because I just couldn't get to
him in time to tell him that I loved him
the prison sentence may be suspended but
Harry's family feel justice has been
served
Harry we've done it
wicked wicked
the woman who killed their son walks
away three years later but living with
what happened for the rest of her life
Lisa Dowd Sky News the Old Bailey